well in my world you can't be
disrespectful on that life ever never
you lyin through your teeth lyin every
other word is a lie and if you can
master that technique then you can get
just about anything you want in any
negotiation I don't care what Paulie
says I don't care what do you accuse you
up I don't care what names he calls you
you don't open your mouth and you don't
answer unless we answer for you what we
tell you to answer if I call you a liar
I lose the argument automatically if I
get upset with you and lose my temper I
lose the argument automatically you
could be the least smartest guy in the
world but you got to make them think
that you're smarter than that
and he says well I want to kill Jerry
Zimmerman I said well then I got a clue
your brother-in-law so what are we gonna
accomplish it he pounds his hand on a
table he says I want them dead
[Music]
for some of you that are wondering why I
brought a mobster here or former mobster
who lives a completed for life right now
is because in the world of business
there's a lot of dirty place a lot of
power place and if you don't know how to
play those plays games someone's going
to eat you up alive without being said
please help me bring up Michael Franzese
they're good
so it's good to see you yeah Michael
good crowd yes good crowd they've been
looking forward to spending some time
with you you know we're talking aback
I'm like Michael what do we talk about
that we haven't already talked about how
many guys have seen the interview about
who anybody's seen the interview so
that's the challenge few people yeah few
people have seen the interview so why
don't we take in a complete different
direction today you and I won power
place that maybe were you know told on
you and probably the stories I wouldn't
mind if we can get into is maybe early
on when you're coming up somebody that
was able to do a power play on you that
you were kind of sitting there saying
wow I can't believe Doug actually pulled
it off on me that helped you learn to
become better yourself on the street and
then later on we can talk about reading
people in rooms and negotiation rooms
many of the guys here sit when investors
competitors buyer sellers vendors
partners how do you read the room who's
really the decision-maker who's the EF
Hutton who's not but having said that
let's go back to power place so coming
up in the streets of New York I mean
these are the times of the 80s these are
tough times
these are competitive times these are
times it's about territory you've got to
be able to stand up and in our world
worst thing that can happen to us go out
of business in your world worse than
that can happen to us you're out of life
it's a complete different ballgame right
you could get killed so what were some
stories or examples you had of power
played played against you and power
plays that you played against somebody
else that was in a more stronger
position than you were you know early on
I got a great education you know that's
that could be a very treacherous life
obviously people you know that and when
I was a young recruit recruit meaning I
had just been proposed into the life and
I now had to prove myself to get my
stripes so you had to do anything and
everything you were told to do and at
the time I was just feeling my way I had
gotten in trouble I had a few
indictments so I was I had really gone
through it and I had a couple of
businesses going I had a market you know
like a market we have all different
stations you got me you got
got the whole thing so we had a meet
division there and Paul Castellano who
was the boss of the Gambino family at
the time he had a lot of people involved
in the chicken business
he's a wholesale chicken guy so one of
his relatives were selling me chickens
we had to buy from him because he was
the budget business it was legit yeah I
think so
so so anyhow I was buying all my
chickens from him it's Memorial Day
weekend the anniversary is actually
coming up and I buy a load of chickens
for him and I'm selling them to people
who wholesale in the given away Memorial
Day were a beautiful weekend so we sell
to this one woman on Tuesday she comes
back and she said you sold me bad
chickens I says what do you mean well
they were all filled with maggots now
they were only in my freezer for a day
right so couldn't have been us so I said
take him back I gave it back the money
to hold [ __ ] so I call up Pauly's guy
and I said listen I'm not gonna pay for
these chickens because it was something
wrong with them there was maggots he
said no you're gonna pay me for the
chickens I said no I'm not gonna pay you
we go back and forth these thoughts
cussing me out I start cussing him out
and so on and so forth he says you know
who I am I said I don't care who you are
you know I'm a young brash guy at that
time and I hang up the phone on him next
thing you know I get a call from my boss
at the time he was a cop regime and and
he just get downtown right away I got to
see it so I jump on my car go downtown I
go to you know downtown Brooklyn I said
what's the problem did you have an
argument with somebody on the phone I
said yeah I said over these chickens and
I explained the story to him he said you
realize who that guy was and I said I
know but he still sold me bad chicken so
I have to pay you know so he said you're
in a lot of trouble that's Paul
Castellanos nephew it got back to Paulie
he's the boss of the Gambino family you
got a lot of trouble here you're not
supposed to get out of control with a
guy like that you always keep your
temper alright so what are we gonna do
he's we're gonna have a sit-down with
him he says but here's the deal when we
get to that table you don't open your
mouth I don't care what Paul he says I
don't care what do you accuse you of I
don't care what names he calls you you
don't open your mouth and you don't
answer unless we answer for you or we
tell you to answer that's the rules
hey you got it without hold us my life I
was 23 23 23 years old so we get to the
meeting and I'm getting abused Patty's
abuse call me all sorts of names you
know who I am who do you think you are I
know who your father is but that doesn't
give you a right to talk to my nephew
like that on and on and on and on and on
and I'm not answering they were
answering for me right so the bottom
line is he says do you want to buy
chickens for me anymore
and I looked at my guy said can I answer
he said I said no I don't want to buy
chickens from you I mean you would have
thought this was like a the biggest deal
in the world right a couple of pounds of
chickens it was always over that so but
you know in that world everything is
very technical they make a mountain out
of a molehill and you know that think
Patrick at that meeting what wish would
happen at these sit downs the old-timers
were very technical
for instance rules of a sit-down let's
make you on a you and I a made guys
we're having an argument you'll lying
through your teeth lying every other
word is a lie if I call you a liar I
lose the argument automatically if I get
upset with you and lose my temper I lose
them the argument automatically you got
to know how to keep your mouth shut
you got to be able to outsmart that
person right and don't let him make you
fall into a trap because a lot of times
if an old-timer was wrong he's trying to
get you into a trap so on technicalities
you lose so I'm starting to figure this
out here so I said look I don't want to
buy chickens from you anymore it's just
but I'm gonna do whatever my boss tells
me to do he tells me to buy him I'm
gonna buy him I said I'm a good soldier
in that regard back and forth back and
forth I took all the abuse and at the
end of the day I didn't have to pay him
for the chickens but I had to continue
buying chickens from that was the
compromise right so now I get in a car
and they turn around and he starts
yelling at me for a minute and there all
of a sudden everything is silent there's
the boss and my capo regime and they
crack up laughing like this was the
biggest funniest thing he said you
Paulie I said I never seen Paulie get so
mad over chickens he said you happen to
do that bubble bud and they were all
will at a good time over but what I
learned at that point I learned just
about these technicalities and how you
got to keep your head
a meeting like that you got to learn to
outsmart people you got to be able to
read the room you know I learned that
whenever I went into a meeting like this
I tried to learn that the personality
the character of the person I was up
against John Gotti for instance you can
never let John Gotti think that you want
an argument his ego wouldn't allow it so
you had to figure out a way to outsmart
him to make him think he won but you
actually got what you want and when you
can master that art you'll do pretty
good and you know whatever I did in my
whole life I was able to apply that to
business in life now so that was my
first but you know they got over me a
little bit but we kind of compromised
but it was a big lesson for me because
that was my first major sit-down against
a major guy so Michael let me ask you
this so in my world I'm in obviously a
lot of times you'll be in a board and
you're negotiating with somebody and you
know somebody in the room isn't telling
the truth what is the benefit of not
calling that out well you know or is it
a different world than the world you
were in well in my world you I mean you
can pay serious consequences you can't
be disrespectful in that life Patrick
you know two made guys two guys that
actually took the oath you can never
disrespect one another never I mean you
know they were made guys could never
disrespect never nice respect so what
does this respect mean calling a guy a
name calling him a liar raising your
voice to him really yeah a made guy
cannot - a made guy no that's that's a
major because the life allegedly is
built on respect so you can never
disrespect anybody it can never
outwardly do it like I'll be honest well
I had a I had a meeting what another
made guy wants and he's trying to get
involved in a gas business and I'm
trying to keep him out he was a guy from
my own family but he was trying to make
a deal with God he to bring them into
the business and I didn't want so I said
can I talk to you a minute and this guy
is doing life in prison right now so we
go in the other room and we get in the
other room I called him every name in
the Sun when we walk out we shaking
hands you're the best guy in the world I
wouldn't let anybody see it because now
if he told anybody I called him that I
call him a liar so they had to believe
me
you mean the same way they had to
believe him so he would never try to
challenge that but no in that life you
can never be disrespectful to one
another no matter what it is you add it
just bite your tongue and and try to
outsmart the guy you know one thing I
learned Patrick in a meeting and you
know this you're the master of this that
sometimes you could be in the meeting
and you could be the smartest guy in the
room and you don't want to let anybody
know that let everybody talk levar we
think that's smaller than you but you
really know what's going on there's
other times when you're in the room you
could be the least smartest guy in a
room but you got to make them think that
you're smarter than them and if you can
master that technique then you can get
just about anything you want in any
negotiation I found out to be how do you
size that up like what what what things
do you look for is the similar to like a
game of poker where you know the guys
still think he's frustrated after he
loses he goes all-in are you looking for
signs to kind of read everybody or have
you done your due diligence before
meeting how does that take place when
I'm able to I do my due diligence I want
to know the personality the character of
the people I'm in with but there's times
when I'll test somebody I'll throw out a
word or two that I know is false and
I'll see how he responds if he wants to
make me think I know what I'm talking
about say something has nothing doing
anything or it's totally absurd and
we'll see how they answer and sometimes
they'll try to they'll give you an
answer and you can start to it you know
they'll indicate to you what kind of
personality they are and really what you
have the main thing is just let people
talk first try to get as much out of
them as you possibly can and then you
can kind of figure it out like with
gaudí a couple of times I had to sit
down with him I knew that he could never
believe that I was winning so in the
midst of the argument I had to figure
out what he really wanted and how I can
get what I want
letting him think that he got what he
wants now know if I'm explaining that
right but you know it's it's all about
how you you you carry yourself it really
is but you got to be prepared so so
again like I'm thinking about for
ourselves or versus yours it did you did
your world Michael did everybody pretty
much know everybody's character like
wasn't like hey Tony I'm about to go sit
with Vinny tell me a little bit about
or did you already know who Vinnie was
or who you know Johnny was because maybe
in our world like if we go into a
meeting and we don't know somebody you
know outside of that like if you're
saying you know you're the smartest
you're not the smartest you know make
yourself the opposite or whatever you
are was there other methods you used to
be able to read people in the room is
there any other thing you did or to look
for I'll give you another another story
I got stories fern you know I had a big
automobile dealership and I had an
office that was on the second floor it
was over looking at carlile big
Chevrolet dealer one of the guys who
work for me was out one day in the lot
and I see him having an argument with
somebody yeah I went back and forth
arguing arguing arguing I don't pay
attention I go sit at my desk few
minutes later he comes upstairs his name
was Jerry I said Jerry was that argument
about he says some guy says we sold him
a lemon he wanted his money back and
he's going back and forth you know he
called me a name I called him a name he
says and then he mentioned that he had a
connected uncle a brother-in-law I'm
sorry connected brother-in-law I said
what do you mean connected he said I he
he didn't have anybody connected he was
just mouthing off he said the guy's name
was Mario he said so I told him go F
Mario a nephew and I said Jerry I told
you don't talk like that this is New
York you never know who some he didn't
know anybody I said well you know
somebody right don't talk like that no I
don't worry about he don't know anybody
okay next day I get a call another made
guy a guy by the name of Tony Tony to
gawk we call him his big guy and he says
Mike I got to see you please come into
Brooklyn so I just happened to say Jerry
I don't feel like driving I got to go
into Brooklyn girl on Long God ride me
so we go into Brooklyn we had a meet at
a place called it was the it was on 18th
Avenue it was called the 19th hole there
was a Chinese restaurant next to it so
we're going to back at a Chinese
restaurant
now here's what happened the guy that I
had to meet was another made guy but I
never met him as a made guy so if you're
a made member of another family I can't
just go up to you and say hey I'm
Michael Franzese I made with the Colombo
is your so-and-so you're made with the
bonanno's we had to have somebody that
knew us both introduced us got it right
Michael amigo Nostra so-and-so and then
we can talk as made guys so tony was
that guy so we're going to back
to the room and is a big old-time guy
big guy there and he's got two guys with
him and Tony says Michael amigo Nostra
mean a friend of ours
Mario I said Mario that sounds familiar
right so I sit down I'm a young guys and
all the guy and it says Mario what could
I do for you is you got a guy by the
name of Jerry Zimmerman with you I said
yeah I know Jerry he pounds his hand on
a table he says I want him dead that's
all I said now I'm putting it together
Mario the scene so now I'm thinking it's
okay Mario do me a favor I got to go to
the restroom I had a long drive in from
Long Island because here's the deal if
they knew Jerry was out there and they
bring Jerry to sit down before I could
prepare him and he says something wrong
I can't save him because I'm a made guy
as a made guy and we always had the
right away so even it was somebody unto
me if he would have said something wrong
he's in trouble in bed truck
what-what-what can't can you do anything
to change that or no no not if he was if
he said the wrong thing and he was
disrespectful in any way or he answered
wrong I can't help that's just the way
it goes so I said man I gotta go a
restaurant so I go outside Jerry's by
the bar I said Jerry Mario's in there
and he's not happy I said get out of
here go up the street that had Dinah
wait for me right so he goes up to the
street for the diner now I'm relaxed I
go back in I says Mario what could I do
for you and he said you know this guy
was very disrespectful
this is my brother-in-law and so on and
so forth and he says you know he he said
eff me and all this kind of stuff and I
said Mario I gotta understand I'm I'm
gonna lie I said Mario your
brother-in-law is not telling the truth
I said I was sitting by the window I
heard the whole thing I said Jerry never
said that your brother-in-law was lying
how could you I know my brother-in-law
20 years is why I know Jerry 20 years
you know we're going back and forth and
he says well I want to kill Jerry
Zimmerman I said well then I gotta kill
your brother-in-law so what are we going
to accomplish it you know this is how it
was literally this is this is literally
I mean you would have thought we were it
was a nuclear explosion this was this
was over he's well I'm gonna put him in
a hospital well I got to put your
brother-in-law in a hospital so what are
we going to do we're gonna go back and
forth with this thing right I'm telling
you Patrick this went on for three hours
because she was an old-timer he wouldn't
budge
not budge an inch right now I'm saying
man this is gonna go all the way up to
the boss we're gonna have a whole
production I said Mario tell me what you
want what do you want out of this
I said no don't even tell me I'll tell
you what I'm gonna do I'm gonna give you
a brother-in-law a new car tell him you
won the argument you want I'll give him
a new car and I'll take care of it Jerry
well I want Jerry and I should stop the
hospital so I'll take care of Jerry he's
my guy take the new car tell your
brother-in-law you won you know whatever
it is you got it made
that's how I finally resolved it right
but listen to this I go out and I'm
yelling at Jerry and everything and they
said Jerry I don't trust this guy I
don't trust them less you happen to be
walking down the street as safe falls on
your head I can't do it so here's what
I'm gonna do you say what as you got a
brother out in California I just go out
to California for a while go relax out
there when I think everything's all
right I'll call you back so and you guys
stand Mario resented me because I'm 30
years younger than him I'm a new guy so
he already don't like me for that reason
alone so jury goes out and about two
months later he calls me up he says hey
chief he says we're gonna be in a movie
business
that's what do you know about movies I
don't worry it's easy we got a script
and all this kind of stuff don't worry
buddies just send me eighty-three
thousand you'll be my partner ice all
right so I sent him eighty-three
thousand dollars and we produced this
movie called mausoleum which was a
horror movie right PS the end result is
a million dollars later we produced this
movie a horror movie that didn't scare
anybody but me I'd be honest with you
but but but that's how I backed into the
movie business and then from there I
realized right away I'll tell you what
you remember Golan and Globus anybody
remember that name Peter Guber would
have told you all about them there were
two guys they had a company and they
were doing all of these you know kind of
exploitation films so I spent a million
dollars on this film so I go and see
them they had offices in New York I said
hey I got this film we spent a million
dollars and he said okay he said we'll
give you 25 grand I said I don't think
you heard me I said I said I spent a
million dollars on this he said I will
give you 25 grand that was it so I said
no thank you so I'd take the film it but
that's when I realized you had to be in
the distribution business so I bought a
distribution company at that point and
how I started to get involved in the
film but in this way back when on an
accident on a mistake because I didn't
pay attention I just sent them the money
I didn't look into anything and I didn't
research anything I just trust the jury
and you know I almost got destroyed on
that film did it end up being profitable
sheriff yeah so saving Jerry's life made
your money yes a lot of headaches but it
made me money yes it was worth saving
his life like with Michael let me ask
you this you know running a business a
lot of people who run a business here
you wonder who supports who is sales
whose operations who's this who's that
in your world you would tell me you guys
got soldiers you guys got earners right
what is the difference between a
personality of a soldier and an earner
and did you ever have a situation where
a soldier also was a great earner but
was there equality for each we had about
at that time we had about a hundred and
fifteen made guys guys that actually
took the oath out of the hundred and
fifteen Patrick 20 of us were earning
that's it 20 of us the other 95 who had
a you know a gambling problem we gave
him a union job we tried to do our best
to support him them but then they did a
lot of the you know the heavy work the
street work because you know it's like
anything else you want to protect the
Golden Goose so the guys that are
bringing in the money you try not to
jeopardize them and the other guys that
are just capitalizing on being part of
that life we made them do the work
you know most of the time was it was
there a personality difference or no
like was there was there a trend amongst
the 95 soldiers that they were now at
business savvy there were not
communicators they were now leaders what
maybe there were tougher guys maybe
there were not what was the difference
between the two yeah I mean you could
tell almost immediately you know you
talked to a guy a few minutes you know
if he's got a head for business and hot
and then you know some of those guys
they're just thrilled to be part of the
life and they want to do whatever they
got it but they don't have to earn I
mean they really don't you got to give
him a job you got to support him looking
at life
we were always shy like in money you
know it's [ __ ] I mean lending it out
in your jury's rates every one of us
were in that
business so what I did with the guys
around me that really couldn't earn on
their own I would give them money and
turn to put out on the street so we
learned a couple points a week I'd give
it to them and then you know that's how
you made guys earn back then it was a
little a little easier you know because
you had that kind of thing going and you
know back then in the 80s Bank money
wasn't easy to come by so we had plenty
of customers that wanted money by the
time I lent a lot of business people
money back then you were making what 20
half to five points boy yeah it would go
from two and a half to five points you
know and then sometimes if you you know
I'll be honestly if you wanted to take
the business over you you know you give
the guy you make a little harder for him
to pay every week so he'd pay five six
seven points but you know it's easy you
come to me at twelve o'clock you got the
money at 2:00 there's no application no
nothing you don't want you go about your
business but it was big business at the
time like a lot of the names that we
know you know the god heed your father
who's legendary yet what he did within
that world and Persico paul castellano
all these guys their names that we've
seen all across Hollywood who were some
of the names that were earners we don't
hear the names like guys who you would
say that guy was legit this guy was real
i what he was doing but it's not
commercialized like some of the other
names Castellano was legit he was a big
honor he had a good head for business he
was you know he had a lot of legitimate
things going and if you're a boss people
are sending your money all the time
you know Patrick when I went into the
gas business I'll tell you how it
happened you know I backed into that too
you know a lot of people have the
impression that mob guys sit in their
social clubs and this is important for
you to know there's sitting there's
social clubs and they target businesses
they said we're going to go after this
is going to go after that doesn't happen
that way 90 percent at a time it's
somebody within the business that has
some kind of scheme to make a little
extra money and they'll come to us and
present it to us because they figure if
they need financing we can give it to
them if they need you know so muscle we
can give it to them and we're never
going to tell on them so they come to us
that happened to me so often people I
wanted to make a few extra bucks that
come to me and that's how I get involved
that's how I got involved in a gas
business so you know
Marya legitimate guys Persico for
instance she was a pretty good earner
when I found out what I had with the gas
business I went to him and I said jr.
here's the deal I'm gonna show you more
money than you ever saw in your life but
and he right away said no drugs we don't
get involved in drugs because we didn't
get involved in it we got involved in
drugs we got killed we weren't a lot big
fallacy out there that mob was pushing
drugs back then not true some guys were
doing it on a sneak but as a business we
didn't get involved so I said jr. it's
not drugs he's what is it I said it's
gas
what do you mean I said well it's a tax
thing that I was that I created I said
but here's the deal everybody's gonna
want to get involved in this from all
five families they're all gonna want to
get involved as soon as you open that
door we're gonna get in trouble I said
it's going to be the same thing that
happens all the time I said you got to
make me win every argument you can't
play politics don't sell me out I told
them just like that as you do that you
make me win every time cuz I'll be right
and I'm going to show you more money
than you ever had let me see at one
point in time after probably six months
I was bringing him in almost two million
dollars a week now in that life two
million dollars a week buys you a lot of
loyalty trust me I never lost an
argument in the gas business never lost
and I went against God II and went
against Castellano I went against
everybody that wanted a piece so you
know does that apply to the real world
look when people are making money with
you that are happy I mean that's the way
it is you know what they're happy I mean
money buys a lot of loyalty in business
you know people don't want to disrupt
that and it's true on the street I think
it's true in real life too I've seen
that you know that powerful
that's very true so when you make money
or partners vendors everybody's happy
you continue doing business and they do
additional things for you you you had a
lot of issues I mean within your career
whether it's government or lawyers or
any of that stuff how do you yourself
see the court system that we have and
outside of the court system
you know today like in a marketplace of
being an entrepreneur building a
business what do you think are some
things business people need to look out
for that has to do with lawyers that has
to do with the government and regulation
subject there but you know listen you
know and I wrote this in my book look I
made a lot of money illegally a lot of
money you know I had this gasoline tax
fraud case I mean deal that at one point
in time we were pulling in seventy eight
million dollars a week okay a lot of it
cash a lot of it I had a divisor system
to send money through wires overseas to
various bank accounts we did different
things to try to hide the money that we
are earning when I finally got in
trouble when the government came on me
with these racketeering laws that are
devastating you don't ever want to get
involved in a Rico very very hard to
defend and of course to millions of
dollars even if you're innocent doesn't
matter just defend these cases are very
difficult and you know in in all my
cases like Giuliani and Deitz me on a
case I had a million dollar bail I paid
my lawyers almost three million dollars
I spent seven months in a courtroom
every single day on trial it took me a
year and a half to prepare I was found
not guilty but it cost me twenty million
dollars Wow twenty million dollars to be
found not guilty yeah so at the end of
the day all right I didn't go to jail
but look at the devastation risers how
many people can handle that you know and
pay those kind of that kind of money me
I don't like a lawyer unless I
absolutely definitely hope there's no
lawyers in here no offense there are a
few but but unless unless I absolutely
need them I try to avoid them that's and
I've been through lawyers my whole life
but III tell you this you know you cut
corners legally that's fine but it
absolutely doesn't pay to do anything
that's gonna bring you heat with the
government of the IRS it took me
literally when I got out of prison I had
a hundred and three million dollar fine
from the IRS 103 million dollars I'll
tell you how my partner in the gas
business became an informant and he
started to testify and all the gasoline
trials right there was probably seven or
eight of them every time witness got to
understand it so I gave Francie's five
million I gave Francie six million next
thing I know I get a letter from the IRS
they assessed me that when the guy was
saying it from the witness stand even if
the guy got the case was acquitted they
still assessed me with it and then they
used to say if you want to pay
by credit card or whatever so I used to
write my credit card and say hit pay
right
I used to get these notes in prison so I
get out I got a hundred and three
million dollar fine from the IRS now how
do you get by on that I'll give you a
little secret I used to go to try to buy
a car and he said to me are you kidding
me you got 103 million dollar fine this
year but let me tell you the flip side
of that if I ordered government 103
million dollars you must know I'm pretty
good owner so give me the car they said
okay you got it
I swear to God I see what are you
worried about the credit report I own
103 you know I can make money okay they
gave me you got to be kidding same way I
bought a house that way one time at the
bank I said don't worry about that I'm
gonna pay when you launder Street you
learned some of that dialogue but anyway
so every year I'm going to court in
Brooklyn on this 103 million I said look
if you claim this money someplace go and
get it
they wrote a books that I got money
buried all over the world and it
investigated me like crazy and making me
sign statements I don't have money in
foreign banks every year I'm going back
every year I'm going back 20 years I
finally get in front of the judge I got
mad with my lawyer says you're not
solving anything for me here they keep
coming I'm not paying him so I told the
judge you know I live in California I
see why he's making me come here all the
time I'm saying the same thing I live in
California change the venue he was so
tired of the case he said I got it's
good idea I'm sending it out to
California right so he sent it out to
California this money about three months
later I get a call from the agent he's
coming I got to see it so I walk in he
looks at me he said I gotta ask you a
question he's got about 20 file boxes in
the back of he says what is all it is
I said well didn't you people tell you
what this is he says all he did was send
me boxes and say you owe 103 million I
said I've been fighting the case for 28
years
we're gonna fight it for another 20
years unless you make a deal and settle
with me now he's okay 20 he says 103
million he's how about we settle for 10
million I said I'll take you here I'll
have any money we're not going to settle
for anything
bottom line is were back and forth I
settled it for two hundred and fifty
thousand dollars
yes no way you gotta hit a vest so he
says you're gonna write me a check I'll
give you 30 days I said you didn't hear
me I don't have any money I said you got
to stretch this out over five years I'll
pay you every month right he stretched
it out over five you gotta be kidding my
god so I said I'll let you want to keep
investigating he just wanted to get rid
of me - he said that let you settle this
thing
103 down a 250 five-year payout that was
it we got a couple of construction
company guys that are very good at
shoveling and digging for money aren't
there any hidden spots you want to
advise them going digging for some money
well here's what they tell okay here's
how the IRS gets you the statute of
limitations is over on any money that I
might have stolen back in the 80s right
but here's how they get you they make
you sign a statement under the penalty
of perjury that you have no money in
farm banks you got no money here they go
down a laundry list like you got no
money in your bathroom in your closet in
a shoebox they go through the whole
thing and there's a ten years that your
limitations on the perjury you know so
they don't get you for the money to get
you for the perjury right so I was
talking a few people today we at lunch
for today yesterday I remember at lunch
and the last statement I signed I have
19 months to go before I have to sign
another one so now I was talking to my
lawyer I said look if I refuse to sign
another one what are they gonna do he
said well probably when you have a year
left they're gonna tell you to come in
and sign another one I said well if I
say no what are you gonna do I said
let's take them to court let's argue
with them a little bit I said because if
we get a lapse of time and there is any
money there and I'm not saying there is
but just case there is you know I don't
know who's in this audience but just in
case there is we're just looking for
cross streets than me that's all we want
maybe that lapse of time I can go grab a
few bucks if there's anything there
until I sign another one but then it's
too late for that